hi there and welcome to the api testing
with postman course
my name is valentine i'm a software
developer and i like to share my passion
for apis with others in a way that is
easy to understand
when i'm not speaking at a conference or
traveling the world
i like to share what i know by creating
short tutorials
and online courses like this one
in this course you will understand what
bozeman is
and why do we need this tool start using
postman to
interact with apis and write api tests
in the last part of the course we'll
explore ways to automate the entire
testing process
you will get hands-on experience using
an api
throughout the course i'll give you
assignments as a way to practice what
you have learned
if you are serious about api testing you
need
to practice on your own make sure you
check the video description for the
course notes
i'll be putting there the most important
steps
you need to take links to resources any
updates
just in case something has changed so
let's get started
before we get our hands dirty let's make
sure we understand the basics
if you are new to apis here is a very
quick introduction
an api is essentially an interface to a
server
that has some data or does some actions
to understand the concept of an
interface think about
any power outlet you have in your home
it does not matter which device you want
to power your laptop
a washing machine or a tv the outlet on
a wall
is designed to accept any plug following
a predefined specification an
interface is essentially a contract i
live here in europe
so all sockets have a specific form if i
bring a device
from the united states or australia this
will not work as they have a different
interface
the apis we are dealing with share a
similar concept
to use an api we need to know and follow
the specification
if you are totally new to apis i do
recommend watching another course here
at free code camp
created by craig dennis to get the
basics of apis right
i think the best way to understand apis
is by actually using them
let's get back to postman postman is a
tool for
interacting with web-based apis that is
apis that work over the internet an api
is like an outlet that a server offers
and instead of electricity we get
data we use postman to plug into this
outlet
but instead of using a physical cable we
use the internet
postman can help us connect to that api
and make sure that the process
of sending and receiving data is much
easier
without that interface to the server it
will be much harder to communicate
so this is why we need postman
in this lesson we'll learn how to
install postman postman uses
a freemium pricing model and for many
use cases
including this course it is free to use
there are two ways of running postman in
your browser
by going to postman.com or
as a standalone app that you have to
download and install
there is also an old and deprecated
google chrome
extension don't use that one i'll be
using the browser
application throughout this tutorial but
apps functionality is very similar
you will find installation instructions
in the course notes i'll go to
postman.com
and sign up for an account the setup
after this is relatively easy and
i will not create a team yet this is it
postman is actively developed by the
time i
finished recording editing and
publishing this course
a new version will be released you may
notice
slight differences from what you see
right now in this video
however i can reassure you that the
principles
stay the same i will update the course
notes
if there's something really important
you need to know
the first thing that i like to do when
opening postman for the first time
is changing to the black theme so in
order to do that
simply locate this gear icon this will
take us to the settings
and from the tab with themes
i'll select the black theme and simply
close this
so let's go ahead and start using an api
in postman
for this course we'll be using an api
that allows us to order a book
now every time we want to start using an
api
we need to understand how to interact
with that api
and the best way to start is always by
looking at the api documentation
now any api out there that you want to
use should have an api documentation
that explains you how to use that api
explains what's available and so on the
api that we'll be using
allows us to have a look at a list of
books and to order
a book so right from the api
documentation that you see here
and that will be linked in the course
notes you'll be able to see that
api is available at this specific
address
and additionally there are some
endpoints that we can use
endpoints offer different kind of
responses and we're going to take a look
at them the first endpoint that we
should look into is the status endpoint
so what i'm going to do is
simply copy the address of the api
and here inside postman from the
workspaces
i will select my workspace workspaces in
postman allow you to
organize your work better let me make
this a bit bigger
so i'm going to go ahead and open up a
new tab and this looks pretty much
similar to what you have in a browser
it's just a bit more advanced i'm going
to paste here the address
and after it i'm going to write status
all requests that will go to this api
must include this address here
i'm gonna hit here the send button
and what i'm gonna get back is in the
lower part of the screen
i'm gonna say status okay so this is our
first
request in postman we have sent a
request
to this api to this status endpoint
and essentially the status endpoint is
just telling us that the api
is available is working as expected
and that we can start using it
next let's take a closer look at what
has happened here
you can load this here in the address
that we are using
this https protocol https
stands for hypertext transfer protocol
http and s means secure so it's a secure
connection
most apis should be using https
but for the purpose of what i'm going to
demonstrate next
http and https are essentially the same
thing
now just to do a bit of http recap
in our communication between the client
and the server
now in this case the client is postman
and the server
or the api is this simple books api
we are using http messages
the http message that goes from postman
to the api
is called a request and what is coming
back from the api
is the response the request
in postman is represented here on the
upper part
and essentially postman allows you to
configure many things about the request
the request will contain the url or the
address where you're sending this
request
in this case we have this is the address
of the api
and this is the endpoint but we are
specifying everything in one address
we also have the request method and
we'll get into that a bit later
we can specify headers and
postman has been kind enough and already
added a few headers for us
and we're going to take a look at those
headers a bit later
and we also can specify a body which
for a get request we don't need to do
that
we'll never do it for a get request
because with a get request
we're just trying to get data we're not
sending any data for example with the
post request
we will specify a body now this is
essentially
what is happening with the request so
again just to
quickly recap postman allows us to
configure the different
properties of the http request
on the lower part of the screen here
this is
the response and the response also
contains
some properties you will find the status
code
in this case 200.
the response will also contain some
headers
and generally both for the request and
the response
the headers are like some meta
information some
additional information that goes with
the message
it's not always necessary to have this
but it just makes the communication a
bit easier
just to give you an example here what's
coming back here is a header called
content type and it's telling
essentially postman that hey
what we have received here is
represented as json you'll see here
application slash json
and using this information postman can
look at the response body and say oh i
know this is jason
so i'm going to display it as json
instead of
using for example text you can see it
doesn't look so nice
so these are like some additional things
that travel both with the request and
the response
the response will also contain what is
probably the most
interesting and most important part the
response body essentially the response
body
contains the entire response whatever we
wanted to get
as an information from the server will
be available in the response body
i'm going to point out the different
parts of the http
request message and http response
message
throughout the course but i just wanted
to do a short recap of what's available
and where you can find this information
inside postman
now let's say that we want to keep this
request
we already have configured here the api
address
and let's say you want to reuse it at a
later point
so what we can do here is click on the
save button inside
postman and we can also
give this request a name for example we
can call it
api status and we cannot simply
save this request as it is we will see
here that this save button is disabled
we have to create a collection
collection is essentially
a list of multiple requests typically
they are all connected to the same api
so if you're working with multiple apis
probably will have a collection for each
individual api
or sometimes even for the same api
depending on the use cases
so i'm going to go ahead here click on
create collection
and i'm going to call it simple book api
click here on this check mark and now
this
request will be saved in this collection
if i go ahead and close the tab we'll be
able to find
here in this part here of collections
we'll see here the collection itself
and if i click on one of the requests
inside the collection
the tab will automatically open up and i
can
run that request again
typically in postman we try to avoid
having addresses or configuration in our
requests
just in case something changes so i'm
going to go ahead
select this address here you will see
here that postman
offers this set as a variable so
essentially we can replace this
with a variable that we can configure in
a single place
so let me show you what i mean by that
i'm going to click here on
set as variable i'm going to select here
set as a new variable
i'm going to call it base url
because this is the url where all our
requests will go
and we'll just use different endpoints
the value that will be saved is
available here
and should not include the final slash
we also have to select the scope now
there are different scopes available in
postman where you can save this variable
i'm going to get into those a bit later
for
this example we're going to select the
collection scope
so essentially this variable will be
saved in the collection
and that's about it i can go ahead and
save this request again
and you will see here if i hover over
this variable
that has this very special syntax here
with
double curly braces in the beginning and
two double curly braces at the end
you will also see the value that this
has
if you want to change this variable all
we have to do is to
hover over the collection name here
these three dots will show up
i'm going to select here edit and from
the variables tab
you'll be able to see here the base url
variable
just in case this set variable option
doesn't appear when you select the
address
don't worry about it you can simply go
ahead and manually
add the variable here
for any variables in postman you will
notice
the initial value and the current value
the initial value is something that will
be shared with other people
for example if you share this collection
with someone else someone in your
organization
a friend of yours or anyone they will be
able to
see the initial value and this is fine
for this api because this is a public
api
the address is known so there's no
secret there
later on we'll be using some secrets and
we may not want to share them with
others
and we're gonna keep them in the current
value so you can
keep in mind like the current value is
what is being used in postman
and this is private to you the initial
value
is something that is not being used when
you're sending a request
and will be shared with others
so if you go ahead and run this request
again we'll see that there's absolutely
no difference
so postman will replace this variable
with the address
and we'll send this request just as
before it is just much
nicer for us to have it all in one place
all right let's go back to using this
api
so far the status endpoint hasn't been
very exciting so let's take a look at
the next endpoint
and this is the slash books
endpoint this will give us a list of
books
so in postman what we can do is to
select the address that we already have
here open up a new tab
paste the address here because this
request is not
in a collection you will see here that
the base url doesn't get resolved it
would say here
unresolved variable because the variable
is only
in a collection and this current request
that we have here this tab
is not saved in that collection so we're
going to go ahead and click here on save
the simple books api is already selected
just in case you don't see it here or
you have multiple collections to select
from
simply select the respective collection
where you want to save the request
and i'm going to call this list of books
and we're going to also change this
to books
so if you're looking here at the api you
will see that we need to submit a get
request
to the slash books endpoint so we have
here
get git is always by default we have
here the base url
slash books so let's go ahead and
click that send button and see what
happens
again on the lower part of the screen
we'll see the response
what's important to notice here is that
we get the status 200
a status 200 always indicates that a
request was understood and that
essentially everything was okay so when
you see 200 okay
this means that everything is fine and
you will see here that we have a list of
different books
what you see here this way of formatting
data
this is called json
and it is very easy to get this
information that is essentially just a
text
and to parse it and use it in
essentially any programming language out
there
so it makes this data very portable from
one system to the other
going back to the api documentation
we'll also notice that
there are some optional query parameters
and this is what we wanted to take a
look in this lecture
so what are query parameters well query
parameters
are some additional data that we can
submit with our request
for some apis they are mandatory and for
some apis
they are optional in this case these
query parameters are
optional so let me give you an example
we can add here
in postman under query parameters you
will see here we have parents selected
and right below that we have query
params so we can write something like
type
and let's say we are searching for a
crime book so i'm going to write here
the value crime
you can notice as i type here the
address itself has changed as well
and you can notice in an address query
parameters
at a point where you see a question mark
and after that
you will see something like a key
value pair so the key is type
then we have the equal sign and then we
have a value
in this case i expect that this will
help us
filter through all these books and only
get the books that are crime books
now this time something different
appears here
you will see first of all that the
status has turned from a status to 100
into a status 400 bad
request when you see a status 400
it generally means that you have done
something wrong
so the api has understood your request
but whatever you have sent is not
correct and most of the time you will
see additional information in the
response body
it says here and it's very important
that you read these errors
sometimes they are a bit technical and
maybe confusing in the beginning but you
just have to
bear with these errors and try to
understand what's going on
so here it will say invalid value for
query parameter type the query parameter
type is
what we're trying to send here this type
and it says here must be
one of fiction or non-fiction so
essentially
the response is telling us hey you have
sent here something
that i didn't expect this is not valid
we only accept
fiction and non-fiction there is no
crime type or something like that
so if i select here fiction
and replace crime with fiction you will
see also the address here has changed
then i will get back the list of only
fiction books
and you can even see here that
everywhere it says
fiction fiction there is no longer known
fiction
now these query parameters tend to be a
bit confusing in the beginning
because it seems quite arbitrary
like why should they be called type or
why does it work this way
and the thing is there is no rule which
query parameters are available can only
be
known by reading the api documentation
we can add parameters for example i can
invent the parameters like
full and we give here the value bar and
notice here how the address has changed
now we have this end sign between the
pairs so this
is how you can send multiple query
parameters pairs
with your request but essentially
nothing has changed
so we can't send data to the api but it
doesn't mean that the api
will look for this data and will do
anything to change it
so this is why it's important to look
into the api documentation
here it's documented they are optional
so these are not required there are two
optional query parameters one is type
and one is the limit
additionally with query parameters in
postman what you can do is to simply
click on this checkbox
and if you unclick it you'll see that
query parameter disappears from the
address
and if at one point you decide that you
don't need that query parameter anymore
you can simply hover over it and you
should notice here this x
you can click on it this will delete
that query parameter
okay time for an assignment now you have
to go
and study the api documentation and
use the limit query parameter
and add that to your request and i also
encourage you to
try out the different values i'm gonna
give you a few moments to pause the
video
and to try this on your own
okay so let me show you how i would
solve this assignment
first of all it's always important to go
back to the documentation
to understand what's going on it's also
important that whenever you're using a
query parameter
that you use it exactly as it's being
stated in the documentation what i like
typically to do
is to simply copy the name so that i
don't enter anything that's wrong make
any mistakes
in spelling that specific parameter
whatever that is
we'll see here that it must be a number
between 1 and 20.
so let's try to understand what this
does
i'm going to simply paste it here so you
can see it has been added
it doesn't have any value yet and let's
say i'm gonna
write here limit two and what i expect
this to do
is to only give us two results back you
will see here now we
have four books that are coming back
and now with limit two we only get
two books back that's great now if i try
something else like for example 25
i'll get here a bad request now again
we have sent something to the api and
the api doesn't allow this
so it says here you cannot get more than
20 books in one request
for for example performance reason so we
have to adapt this to something that is
being accepted by the api
so we can see back 2 has been valid was
saying earlier that it's so easy to
write something different so for example
if i write limit with a capital l
i will not get back only two results
there will be more results
so essentially we can say that limit
with a capital l and limit written all
in lowercase
there are two different query parameters
and the api is only recognizing one of
them
and totally ignoring the other one it is
like writing here
foo and with a value 2 makes no
difference
let's continue exploring this api we now
have a list of books
but as you can see there's not really a
lot of information about each book
and the reason for that is because this
view here where we see a list of books
is a simplified view
if you take a look at the documentation
here the next endpoint that we can use
is to get a single book and this time
the path will look a bit different
so we're going to copy this path here
open up a new tab paste it here
and of course you also have to use the
base url
so the first step is simply saving it in
the collection
to get a single book this is how i'm
going to call this
and as soon as the request is inside a
collection
i can use the syntax with double curly
braces so
double curly braces and a
variable that we're trying to use is
base url
and this has been detected
you're probably wondering what is with
this book id here
in the address this is what we call
a path parameter or a path
variable because as the name variable
implies
it changes all the time this endpoint
allows us to specify a value
for this path variable which represents
one of the books that we are trying to
get additional information
on we look back at a list of books
you will see here that each book has an
id you'll see here id 1
ids 3 id4 id6 and so on
so let's go ahead and edit here
the path variable book id and put in the
variable 1.
and just a few seconds later we now have
only one book that we're getting so this
endpoint
allows us to get a single book but we
now get more detailed information we can
see
the id and the name we already knew that
but we now see information about the
author
book code the price of the book how many
books are in stock and so on
so this is the purpose of this endpoint
to give us detailed information
instead of having here a list of books
which contain really a lot a lot of
information
we can get a specific information from
this
specific api we just need to know the
book id
if we enter here a book id that doesn't
exist for example
100 what you will get back is 404
not found you probably know 404 not
found
from browsing the internet when you end
up at a page that doesn't exist anymore
the same principle applies to apis in
this case we're trying to get the book
with id
100 and the api is telling us hey there
is no book
with id 100 this will always be
reflected also in the error itself
what is interesting about the path
variables
is that they are different from the
query parameters that we have used
before
first of all you will notice here there
is no question mark
apart from this this book id
key this is not something that will be
sent
so to make it even more explicit
this is what will be sent you will have
the base url
slash books slash one postman will
replace
that path parameter with a value
we see it here in the editor just a bit
nicer it's easier for us to see that
and one here will be part of the path
just as books is part of the path but
books is always there books doesn't
change but here we can have id1 we can
have id2
we can have id4 and so on this is why we
prefer this syntax
where we specify here the book id
how we call this we can call it book id
we can simply call it id
it doesn't really matter because as i
mentioned the key itself
compared to the query parameters will
not be sent
it's also possible to use both query
parameters and
path parameters there's nothing
preventing you from adding a query
parameter called full
with a value bar but this is something
that the api needs to accept
as in the query parameters if you're
just sending some random data
the api will totally ignore it
so let's remove this query parameter and
save the request
let's say we have identified the book
that we want to
order so what would be the next step
again we have to jump back to
documentation
and to understand how to submit an order
you can now see that the endpoint that
we need to use is orders
but this time also the http request
method we're no longer getting data
with post we are sending data
so we need to create a post request with
postman
i'm gonna copy this endpoint
and go through the same process once
again
if creating this request manually is too
time consuming
you can also go here to your collection
to an existing request
click on the three dots and click on
duplicate
we'll create a copy of that request
where we already have this
request being saved so all we have to do
is to enter the new path
and we can also change the name so for
example here we're gonna
name this request order book
as you remember we can no longer use a
get request
if we try get request this will not work
we have to select a post request
now as you remember with a post request
we have to supply a body
so if we go here to the body you will
see that we don't have a body
but we are anyway missing something for
this so i'm gonna simply click on send
and see what happens
of this time we're going to get a 401
unauthorized and it says here in the
error missing
authorization header when working with
apis
some endpoints as for example status or
this book's endpoints
they were public and required no
authentication
essentially anyone can use them other
endpoints
for example this one where we're trying
to essentially create
something create an order they can be
private and require authentication
this is totally up to the api provider
there is no
hard rule telling you that you know for
this case you need authentication for
others you don't need
for some apis they are totally public
but especially if you're trying to
create data
most of the time you will have to deal
with some sort of an application
if look here at the api it will also say
here that it requires authentication
so in order to figure out how to deal
with this we have to look into the part
of
how to get this authentication working
so if we scroll further down the page
we'll see this part
with api authentication it says here to
submit or view an order you need to
register your
api client api client is in our case
postman the client
server communication is what we're doing
we are the client we are sending
http messages to the server and the
server is responding
what essentially means is that we need
to register ourselves with the api
and it is a way for the api to identify
who's sending this request and who's
creating the data if there's any data
that has been created
there are many authentication methods
when it comes to apis
and it is impossible to go into all of
them i just gonna explain to you a very
typical use case that you may encounter
essentially with any public api that
you're trying to use
the purpose of this registration is to
obtain
what is known as an access token
nexus token is like a temporary password
that you're getting
and you can use that password with all
your requests
and in this way you're authenticating
yourself don't worry if it doesn't make
sense right now
we'll get to it in a second
so this time we need to submit another
post request
and this post request has to go to this
endpoint api
dash clients and it also needs to
include
the following json body and here's an
example
so again i'm gonna simply go ahead and
save this
order book i'm gonna duplicate
it let's call it register
api client
and endpoint will be slash api
clients you can add a final
forward slash or not for most apis it
will not make any difference
as you recall we have to select here the
post http request method
because the post will allow us to submit
a request body
i'm going to click here on body and
instead of none which essentially means
doesn't send any data with a request
in order to submit a json request body
we have to select here raw
and from the drop down that you see here
we're going to select
json
let's jump back to the api documentation
and
luckily here we also get an example in
regards to how
this request body should look like so
i'm going to simply go ahead and copy
this example here
and i'm going to paste it here so
essentially what we're sending here
is we're giving ourselves a name and
we're also specifying our email address
it's very important that when you're
submitting json to ensure that this json
is valid for example if i don't put
these values
between double quotes or if i forget one
of these double quotes here
something red will show up essentially
if you see something red when you're
trying to submit json
it's not a good sign and you should go
ahead and fix it this case everything
looks well so i'm gonna click on send
this time we get a different status code
and this one
is 201 created two one created is pretty
similar with
200 which means okay everything that
starts with two
something is typically a good sign means
that everything was okay
everything which starts with four
indicates that there was something wrong
with the recurs that we have submitted
and if there's anything like
500 it typically indicates a server
issue or
some other problem so now we have
submitted
our name and our email
and we got back an access token this is
the password that we can
use in the upcoming request so i'm going
to simply double click on it
copy it go to our collection
click on edit open here the variables
close this documentation here i'm going
to write here
access token
now the initial value is something that
i don't want to provide just in case i'm
sharing this with anyone
this is my token i don't want to share
with anyone else so i'm not adding it to
the initial value
current value is what is being used by
postman inside this installation
i want to make sure that this access
token is saved because if i try to
submit this request once again with the
exact same data
i'll get back the error api client
already registered
and you will see here that we get
another status code
409 conflict so it indicates that
something
went wrong essentially this api client
has already been registered
so make sure that you use another email
address it doesn't have to be a
real email address for this api
now we have this token so we can close
this request
and let's go back to our post request
now as you remember here it says
missing authorization header so we have
to go back to this
header thing that we kind of avoided so
far
when working with apis you will not be
provided with a form where you can add
your username and password
so we always need to somehow send this
information with
our request especially where
authentication is necessary
typically you will add this
authentication information to the
headers
some apis allow you to add them as query
parameters
some of them allow you to add them in
the body but it's quite common to add
them to the headers
now there are already a few headers here
that postman has added for us
and we can take a quick look at them
essentially one of the most important
ones
is user agent which essentially
identifies who's making the requests
it's also telling like which kind of
responses are accepted and so on and
here we have to add this authorization
header
now we don't want to get too technical
right now
and postman is known for making things a
bit
easier for us there is this
authorization tab here
and if i click on it you will see here
that we have
different types of let's say
authorization helper that we can use
now i know the list is a bit long and i
won't be able to get
into each of them but essentially what
we have here
is a token so we're going to select the
beer token
and you'll see here a simple form where
you can simply add your token
now we don't want to add our token here
we will use
our variable so again using the syntax
access token we're going to select it
and you will see here it's available so
double curly brace in the beginning
then exactly the name of the variable as
you had it
and if this request is saved in the
collection and you hover over it
you should be able to see the value
all right perfect now if we come back to
the headers
you will see here that postman has
auto-generated
one header that is called authorization
exactly the header that we're missing
and it has a value in a very specific
way
this beer token authorization must
include the word
beer then a space and then essentially
the token
so that's about it instead of manually
doing this and we can definitely do that
manually as well
we can use this authorization helper in
postman and postman will take care of it
it's absolutely the same thing just
wanted to show you like what's happening
from a technical point of view
all right let's hit this send button
once again
and see what's happening now this time
we're not getting a 401
we're still getting a 4 something we're
getting 400
band requests and it's just telling us
invalid or missing book id
so we're trying to submit an order we
haven't specified
anything but we'll fix that a bit later
all right so let's go back to submitting
this order we wanted to
order a book and we have to tell this
api which book we want
so if we go here to body and select for
example
raw and say something like we want
book with id1 and submit this request
i'm afraid the api will not understand
what we mean by this
so again we have to look at the api
documentation to try to understand
how to do this how to submit this
information
how to specify what we want
so in this case in order to submit an
order you'll see here an example
and again we have to submit a request
body
in a json format and include these
properties
and luckily again we have here an
example that we can simply go ahead
and copy so i'm going to totally replace
this
with this json here
and i wanted to take a moment to talk
about json
because i know a lot of people just
getting started with json
sometimes have issues and the most
common issue
is generating invalid json
osman as i mentioned before tries to
take care
and help you off if you make any
mistakes still
it's kind of important to understand
what json is
now json is essentially just a key value
way of sending data so for example here
the key is book id
and the value is 1 and again we have a
comma here separating this
let's say values that we're sending key
value pairs
and the next key value pair is the
customer name
and it has the value john if we try to
write something different
instead of this column we are adding
here an equal sign
this is not valid so it has to match the
syntax of
what json is essentially from a
specification point of view
we have these quotes here so if you
specify one of the keys
without using the quotes this is again
not valid json
so we need to specify these quotes they
also have to be double quotes they
cannot be single quotes
one exception to these quotes and you
probably already see it here
one is not between codes and you may be
wondering
why is that well the truth is
we're using quotes when we're sending
strings
the reality is that we are sending a lot
of strings for example
john is a string if we have an address
that's a string as well but one here
is a number we can also have a boolean
for example if we specify something like
true
or false that is also fine so there are
a few exceptions and if we put for
example
one between two double quotes
this would be valid json but this will
no longer be
technically speaking a number it will be
a string
all right so just keep in mind that you
need to submit
valid information to the api if you're
submitting an invalid json
well that api will not be able to
understand what you mean
and let me give an example i'm removing
this comma here
you will see here postman is trying to
warn you you don't care about it
still go ahead and you're getting
something back like
this is not processable i cannot work
with this this is what the api is
telling you
so always pay attention make sure that
you understand what postman is trying to
tell you
make sure that the json that you're
sending is valid
so welcome to the next assignment and in
this assignment
you have to create this post request
which should be
already done by now submit it and
see what's happening additionally i want
you to
see and identify a book inside a
collection of books
that has a stock of zero so essentially
it's not in stock
and try ordering that book as well and
see what's happening
i'm gonna give you a few seconds to
pause the video and to do the assignment
on your own
and i highly encourage you to practice
this
all right so let me show you how i would
solve this assignment
essentially we should have a valid json
here
so if we go ahead and hit the send
button
what we're getting back here is the
status tool one created
so we have successfully created this
order it even says here the response
created true
and we're getting back an order right
here that's totally fine
so it means that we have submitted an
order now and this order will be
processed
of course the order that we send here is
very simple doesn't include an
address phone number and so on so it's
not 100 realistic
but the idea remains the same
now what's happening if we're trying to
submit an
order for a book that is no longer
available
first of all how do we find this book
well we have to go back to the list of
books here
and you can see here with the filters
that we already have
all of them are available i'm going to
remove the full here
and you will be able to see here that
the book with id2
says here available false so let's take
a look
inside that book to see what's happening
so i'm going to go to the get
single book endpoint and specify a book
id
to and you'll see here that the current
stock
is zero so i'm wondering what's gonna
happen if we try to order this book
and we're gonna get back a 404 not found
i'm gonna say this book is not in stock
try again later
so this is the assignment
when we're trying to test apis and
especially when we need to send data
we have a tendency of reusing
essentially the same data over and over
again
and most of the time this will prevent
us from identifying
issues with the api especially if we've
been asked to test and ensure that that
api will work properly
this case there are not so many things
that can go wrong we already tested
what's happening with the book id that
is in stock and another one that's not
in stock
you can also try and play out with
different values but
how about if we get some support from
postman in
trying out different values and for
example here for the customer name
how about you know generating a random
customer name
so that we don't send all the requests
with john
unfortunately there is a functionality
hidden in postman
that allows us to send random data with
our request
and that is a special kind of variable
it's called a random variable
so i'm gonna remove john here but make
sure that i keep the double quotes
because if we're trying to send a string
without double quotes
you know it it's not gonna be valid json
so i'm gonna open here two double curly
braces
enter the dollar sign and as soon as i
do this
you will see here a huge list of
variables that are available
now i'm not gonna go through all of them
i'm gonna write here random
and let's say we want a random full name
all right so let's click here on send
and again we're gonna get the error that
the book is not in stock so let's try a
different one
and now again a new request has been
sent
the problem now is we're sending
something but we have no idea what we
have sent
fortunately postman has another neat
functionality
and that is the postman console it is a
bit technical and a bit geeky but it is
important to use it
as one of the most important tools when
you are using postman
you can find a postman here right at the
bottom of the screen
should say console and it will open up
inside postman typically you should
already have like a long
list of things here that we don't need
at this point
so what i'm going to do i'm going to
click here on clear
let's submit this request once again
and now this time we'll see here the
post request going out
with a full address at the orders
endpoint
i can expand it by clicking here
you will see here the request headers
these are not interesting
but also the request body so let's click
here on the request body this will open
up
an additional window here inside the
console and you will be able to see
the request body that we have sent the
postman console is particularly useful
for debugging when something goes wrong
when you don't understand what's going
on
always come back to the postman console
and take a look at the request
see what happened there you'll see here
the book id is one this is the customer
name that we have sent so this has been
randomly generated by postman if you
don't need it anymore
the first x here is for closing the
request body
and the other one is for closing the
console
that's it
i want to take a short break now from
postman and
so far in the course you have seen many
ways on how to use postman
but in this session i wanted to get a
bit into how
not to use postman so just to make clear
you have seen that we have used postman
to interact with apis
postmate is not a tool for dealing with
user interaction
think about if you have a website with a
form or buttons
and you need a tool to click through
those boostman is not a tool that deals
with such things
it's just working with apis postman is
also not a tool for doing any
performance testing
or any kind of tests where you need to
send a lot of requests in a very short
time frame and
also postman is not designed for
security testing
you can use it for security testing but
this is not the primary focus of the
tool
there are many other tools out there
which i think do a much better job at
helping you test to see if an api is
really secure
so i hope this short lesson has helped
you understand if
postman is the right tool for what
you're trying to do
we have already submitted a few orders
so maybe now it's time to
take a look at how many orders we have
in order to take a look at that again we
have to look at the api documentation to
see if
there's anything that can help us in
this regard
see here right below submit an order
there's also this get
all orders endpoint which is essentially
the same
endpoint slash orders but this time we
only
have a get request we're not trying to
create an order we're just getting an
order
we're getting essentially all the orders
that we have
so let's go back in postman and we're
gonna be lazy again
and simply duplicate this request
get all book orders will be
the name of our request because we have
duplicated this
we also have the authorization header
with us
so this request again requires
authorization
and instead of post we're going to
simply select get
and luckily if looking here inside each
order
we'll see a list of all the orders that
we have
each order has an order id which you can
see here
it's no longer a number it's a string it
says here which book we have ordered
who's the customer name also the
quantity and such
information and these other orders have
been created using this
random full name functionality that we
have found from postman
and this has ensured that we can now
have different names that we're sending
so essentially these are all the orders
that we have
in this assignment i'm asking you to
take one of these existing orders
and to view it individually so instead
of viewing all the
orders take one order id
and find out if there's an end point
that allows you to view a single order
id
give you a few seconds to pause the
video and after that i'll show you how
to solve this
all right so let's jump back into the
api documentation and see what we can do
you will see here we have an endpoint
get an order
and the structure of this endpoint is
pretty similar to the one
where we were trying to get an
individual book so
just gonna go ahead and copy this
go back in postman duplicate one of the
requests that we have
and i'm going to replace here orders
with this endpoint
make sure there are no spaces or
anything like this because this will
break
and postman will send this request to
the wrong endpoint i'm gonna simply
rename this to get an order
and additionally we need to specify this
order id so if i'm just sending this as
it is right now
essentially postman will not send
anything so we will send
the request to the orders endpoint so
you will see all the orders
just in case you're wondering what
happened there and if i type in
some value that doesn't exist i will get
back a 404 not found
so i need to get a real order so the
real order let's say would be this one
for john
i'm gonna paste here the order id
exactly as it was in the other request
and now we will see
an individual order that you are getting
here
so that's it
you know if i'm looking at this order
right now i'm not really happy with the
customer name
john it's not the full name so how can
we change this
now if we go back and use the
post request once again to order book
will essentially create two orders
so i was wondering if there's any way
how we can
update this and luckily there is
so here at the api documentation will
notice this endpoint
which says update an order and it will
use the
http request method patch to update this
existing order
and it will require authentication
and it only allows us to update the
customer name
depending on the api you could update
the entire order itself or only some
specific properties
depends from api to api and again here
we're gonna get an example on how to do
this
so let's try to update this order
i'm going to simply copy here this
customer name
and essentially the structure is the
same as the one with getting an
order so for that reason i'm gonna
duplicate this
rename it so that i can easily identify
it
and for some reason the parameter here
got lost
maybe i forgot to save it here before
creating it
absolutely no worries i can
simply go ahead and copy this from here
we'll have the exact same request i'm
gonna try it again with get
i'm noticing that this is the order that
we're trying to update
so i'm gonna select here patch and
patch is again one of these http methods
that
allows us to send a body so i'm going to
click here on body
i'm going to select raw and again we're
sending json
i'm going to paste it here
so let's add here another value and we
can
even use this postman random variable
here so let's say a random last name
this would be a good one all right
so let's save it let's run it again
and we're not getting back anybody and
this is totally fine
because the status will be indicated
through the http
response status and this is 204 again
204 indicates that everything was okay
so we're trying to get that order again
you will see here now the customer name
is john anderson
and we have managed to update the same
order so the order id
remained the same the book that we're
ordering remain the same
the only thing that changed is the
customer name
now let's assume that we already have
too many
orders here and that we're trying to you
know delete some of them
with patch itself we can just update
information but we need a way now to
delete this order let's say
we already wanted to test something but
we no longer need it
so going back to the api documentation
you can notice that there's also an
endpoint for deleting an order
essentially the path
for all these operations from getting an
order updating an order
or deleting an order remained the same
the only thing that changed
was the http request method we had used
get we had used
patch we had used post to create an
order
and now we are using delete
so delete doesn't require anybody we
just have to specify
in this case which one is the order id
again what we're using here is just an
example
and it's always important that you study
the api documentation of the api that
you're trying to use
just because a respective endpoint works
in one way
with one of the http methods for this
api it doesn't mean that all apis work
exactly the same
so to update an order i'm going to
simply go ahead here
click here on duplicate
i'm gonna call it delete order
and i have to select the correct
http method this one is delete
the order id is already pre-filled here
so all i have to do
click on send i'm going to get here 204
no content
but if we're still unsure if this worked
properly we can go back to get an order
so if we're trying to get the same order
that we have deleted you notice it's no
longer here
and especially if we try to look at all
the orders that we have
you will see now we have one order or
less so
obviously the delete order worked
properly
let's save this as well and it will also
show up
correctly here in the collection
you can notice that we already have
quite a few tabs open
so let's go ahead and close them so what
you can do
is simply close all tabs
and if there are any unsafe changes
you'll have the possibility of
saving those changes
if you have a lot of tabs and you don't
need them anymore
because they only contain temporary data
you can simply click
here on the three dots and select force
close all tabs
and you will not be asked
welcome to the second part of the course
where we start laying the foundations
for automating the testing of this api
as you have seen so far we started
working with the api but there's still a
lot of manual work involved
if someone changes the api we have to
retest everything manually
and this is not very fun and also time
consuming
instead of verifying the api with our
own eyes
we want to let postman do this for us by
writing api tests
we also want to avoid any manual
intervention
like copy pasting data from one request
to the other
automation means that we let postman do
the work
and we only step in if something goes
wrong
by the end of the course you will know
how to test this api
with just one command or only one click
this is the most exciting part of the
course
so let's get started
alright so let's get started with
writing api tests
so far we have manually tested this api
and
we went through all these requests and
essentially we created
sort of like workflow we first of all
checked if the api status is correct and
we
got a list of books we looked at a
single book we ordered that book
we took a look at all the orders we got
an individual order
we updated that order and then finally
we deleted it and of course
for some of these operations we also
needed to register
ourselves with this api
the way we have looked at this is take
for example this api status
well essentially for postman as long as
the request has been sent and
something is coming back this has been a
successful
request response interaction postman has
no idea
unless we tell postman too if this was
successful or not
and we tell this by inspecting the
response we
typically are looking at the response
we're not looking so much at request
because we already know the request
look at the response and we're looking
at for example the status code
we think here 200 and we're looking here
at the body
and we're seeing status okay so
instead of us manually looking at this
information
let's tell postman to do this for us
and in order to do that we're gonna
switch here to this
part of the request where it says here
tests
and this is where we can write tests
what you can write in this window here
is programming code it's
javascript if you want to be very
specific about us
luckily if you're not really into
programming or you're just getting
started with it
don't worry i will try to make things as
easy as it gets
postman here has this window with this
so-called code snippets they essentially
allow you to
quickly do a few things with javascript
without writing a lot of code
and especially for us as beginners right
now that's totally fine
the most simple test that we can write
is to test that the status code is 200
so if we scroll here the snippets you
should be able to identify
one of the snippets which says here
status code code is
and if you click on it this code will be
generated
now if for some reason the snippets have
changed or you cannot find it anymore
don't worry you simply can go ahead and
type it as you see it here
now this is a piece of code that will be
executed
when the response has arrived and
postman will check
if the status is 200. and you can even
see here
from the assertion that we're writing
here it's kind of like easy to
understand it says here
pm.response not to have
status 200 so it's relatively easy to
read
so again you know what's happening here
and also postman knows what's happening
here so let's submit this
and now if we were paying attention here
in the test results
it will say one from one and if you
click on it
you will see here a path mapping green
says status is 200 200.
whenever we are writing tests we always
must ensure that it will also fail
just in case we made any mistakes when
typing this code here
it's totally possible may break this
test or may
always show that it's working when it
sometimes is not working
so let's try and fail this test we can
fail these tests by
entering here an address that doesn't
exist so for example if i write here
status
foo and simulate
that api will send me something else
back
i can get this test to fail and you will
see here
we expect the status code to be 200 but
we're getting this
assertion error expected response to
have status
200 but got 404 as you see here 404
i'm gonna fix it back but this was just
a small test to indicate that
what we have written here is working
properly
all right now if the status code is
let's say
good but not enough for our use case we
may also want to take a look
at the response body for most apis the
response body
will be written in json this is just a
very simple way to send data from the
api
to postman or to any let's say
programming language
and to transform it and use it there
essentially the data that is coming back
is relatively easy to use and understand
by other programming languages
so let's try and write a test that will
verify that the status
is indeed okay
now the first step that we need to do is
to parse the response
and people generally wonder when they
hear about parsing
is like why do we need to parse it
and the reason for that is what you see
here this is json
but this is essentially just text it's
not an
object that we can use inside javascript
so for that reason in javascript what we
will do is we're going to define
a variable so const
response will define a javascript
variable
and we're going to initialize it equal
and this is something that comes from
postman so i'm going to write
pm.response
this holds the response and we are going
to call
a function called json
and a function call in javascript is
always like this
so inside this response variable in
javascript we will now
have the response which will be parsed
from json into a javascript object
if you want to take a look inside and
see what is the value of response
we can go back to our old friend the
postman console
by default the postman console will not
record
the values of different variables that
are available unless
instructed we can use for example
console.log
which is again a function and we'll
specify in this function
parameter and that parameter is the
response
so let's go ahead and open the console
again
i'm going to clear everything that you
see inside here
hit send one more time
and you will see here the request that
has been sent this is locked by default
and then you will see here from our
console.log statement
you will see here this javascript object
which has been created from parsing the
json response
the way this is represented looks pretty
similar to json
but it is not json it is a javascript
object
all right now let's say we're trying to
get to this
okay here and
we have here an object that has a
property called status
now in javascript there are two ways on
how we can
get to that property we can write
response
that status
and we can lock that information and
you'll see here now it says okay
or the alternative is to write
this status between the square brackets
as a string
and this is sometimes needed when
dealing with
names that contain let's say a
hypen or some other special characters
maybe a space or something like that
that will break the syntax so this is
another way to use it but most commonly
i would see it in this way
both of them will get back with okay
now we have accomplished a very
important thing
and that is getting to the data that we
are
trying to test if we cannot
read it if we don't have it in our
console after using it with console log
there's no point in writing a test yet
so especially
if you're a little bit confused about
json and javascript and parsing and
everything
make sure first that you see what you're
trying to test
inside console.log all right so now we
already have it there we know that it
exists
so let's write another test
a test in postman always starts with
pm.test
and pm.test is a function
that takes two parameters so you can see
here pm.test this is a function
the first parameter will be the name of
the test
so let's say here status should
be okay it's totally up to you what to
write inside here
and the second parameter this is a bit
more tricky
we have to specify the second parameter
after a comma
and this will be a so-called callback
function
and this has a syntax like this one
or it can start like function this one
these two syntaxes are compatible with
one another
this one here is a bit more modern
now i'm gonna hit here enter and this is
where we can start
writing our assertions by default if we
leave this test
empty it will not do anything it doesn't
really matter what we have here for a
name it will show it here as
past even though we have no assertions
now we're gonna start with something
very simple and
what we're gonna do here is write
something like pm.expect
and we can expect for example one
dot 2 eql to equal
1. you have to be very careful when
you're writing the syntax
and it has to look exactly like i have
it here
let's hit send again if i'm seeing
expected 1 to equal 2 we expect this to
fail
it will say here assertion error
expected 1 to deeply equal 2.
don't worry about this deeply equal
essentially it's failing and it's
telling that one doesn't be equal to
all right now how can we
make this assertion that status is okay
we already know that this object here
with this property
contains okay so let's check if it
contains okay
so instead of this expect hardcoded
value one
i'm gonna paste it here and here between
double quotes
i'm gonna write okay
so let's send it again we'll see that it
passes
and if i write something else for
example not okay
it will fail and i will say expected
okay too
deeply equal not okay so this is an
additional test that we have written
on top of checking that the status is
200.
if for some reason where again let's
call here the foo
status for endpoint that doesn't exist
we expect some things to happen so first
of all
we'll get here 404 not found but
also here this entire code that we have
here will also fail because
we're no longer getting json this is not
possible so it will
fail all together but this is just a
very simple way on how you can ensure
that
this simple endpoint is working properly
it is now time for another assignment
based on what you have learned
in the previous lesson i want you to
write
a status code test for all the requests
inside the collection and i also want
you to make sure that those tests will
fail
if needed i'm going to give you a few
seconds to pause this video
and after that i will show you how i
will create this
all right so there's nothing preventing
us from getting started with what we
already have
i'm just going to change here be the
syntax make it a bit more modern
but as i mentioned before this is
absolutely equivalent
and shouldn't make any difference i'm
going to copy this
and let's take it here to the list of
books
click here on tests kind of paste it
and again the status that i'm getting is
200
i'm seeing here the test results are
working if i'm trying something else
let's say books
it will fail with a 404 so this is
perfectly fine
getting a single book again pasting
absolutely the same test
and i will be absolutely sure that this
will fail as well
okay order book now this is interesting
let's see what happens if we simply
paste this test here
and you'll see here that the status that
we're getting is 201 created
that the test will fail
we can adapt this here to check for the
status 201
and also make sense to adapt the test
name this is of course not necessary
but it's just a good thing to keep it
consistent
all right so this one is now passing as
well
these other ones are absolutely the same
and i'm not going to waste a lot of time
making sure that they work as they will
always return here
200 right
this is another interesting one trying
to here to get an order
and that order doesn't exist anymore so
we're getting 404 not found
and also our test is failing so this is
a good thing that this has happened
we can look back here at the order book
result
we can get one of this order ids
put it here in the parameters
and running here the test
we'll see that the status is 200 so this
has worked
we have to do the same for the next one
where we are
patching it
so if i'm switching between too many
tabs here i'm now inside a
patch request pasting the test
i should have gotten a 204
and i'm expecting for 200 so i'm going
to change here 200 in 204
and now this one is passing as well
deleting an order is pretty similar i'm
gonna first let it fail
i got in here 404 not found i should
also get a 204
getting now the right order id
and putting it inside a parameter
okay another test that is passing and
also this with the registration of the
api client
i have to identify the right test and
i'm going to paste it here as well
if i recall correctly because we are
creating something
we expect here to get to 1.
obviously for saying the same data again
this will not work
but now we have a simple test
that tests that each individual requests
in this collection returns back the
status code
and as you have already seen this is
already a pretty important test this
already gives
us a pretty good idea if that request
was successful or not
as you have noticed in the previous
assignment one thing is particularly
annoying
and that is copy pasting this order id
from one request to the other
essentially we start here after we
have this order book we're getting an
order id
and after that we want to go through all
the other requests we have to paste it
over and over again
and to be honest we don't like that very
much now i mentioned in the beginning
of the course that postman has different
variable scopes
and essentially those variable scopes
are
collection variables that you have seen
so far there are
also global variables which is a
variable type that is available inside
the entire workspace
for all collections not just for a
specific collection
or they are also environments
environments
they are useful if you have different
environments so for example if you're
developing software
and you have a local development
environment
local host you have a testing
development environment
and you have a production development
environment then you can define
multiple environments and you can easily
switch within them
and having here for example the base url
you can easily swap that
with testing environment or a production
environment or localhost
getting a bit of topic right now in
terms of this the problem that we're
trying to solve
is to use a postman variable to store
this order id
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to copy the value
and i'm going to click here on this eye
icon
right here in the corner and what we're
going to do here is to define
a global variable just as well we could
have defined
this inside our collection as a
collection variable
but to be honest this is sort of like a
transactional data we
don't really want to save it inside the
collection we can just
you know throw it in these global
variables
and not worry so much about it so we're
going to click here on this
edit i'm going to define here the
variable
key which is order id of course you can
call it as you wish
i don't really care about the initial
value
i just gonna paste here the current
value the current value
is now this one
now next time when we create this
request
we can take this order id
again if you lost it here you can simply
click here on this eye
you'll see here the values and you can
even click here on the current value
and easily change it make sure you don't
add any spaces or new lines where you're
pasting data
so now at the next request the
get all book orders there's nothing that
we need to change but then
when we have here get an order instead
of manually specifying this parameter
here
i'm gonna use here double curly braces
order id
you'll notice that this is the order id
that we have just saved
so i will even copy this variable here
go to the next request replace this as
well
go to the delete order replace this here
as well
so next time when we're clicking here on
orders let's see gonna happen so we're
gonna get a new value
let's get here a new value again click
on the environment
replace it here if i'm trying to get an
order
i will see that order and it should be
exactly the same so we can
cross check what we have here for a
variable to what we're getting back
in the response i can
update that order
i can go back and look at the updated
information
and of course i can go ahead and delete
that order
and if i'm trying to get it again it
will
not be there anymore and as you have
noticed
the postman tests have been executed in
the background
and they already give us an idea if
everything went okay or not
so we don't even have to look at
response body or anything like that in
this case
we went outside of what was expected in
terms of the flow
but the rest of the tests were useful
and
now we have managed to reduce a bit the
amount of
manual labor that we have to do in order
to test this out
if we look back at the collection we'll
notice that we still have a few requests
that contain some let's say
hard-coded data and it all starts with
this
list of books where we have looked at
some of these books we have identified a
book id
and we have used a book id in some of
the upcoming requests for example
get a single book we have here an id
that is hard coded
and of course then the next request with
ordering the book we have again the id
here so this kind of like hard-coded
data
makes our tests and our entire
collection
a bit susceptible to changes for example
if that book is being removed
and having like this hard-coded value
there will not do
us any good so for that reason we have
to find a way
to make everything a bit more dynamic
so looking at this list of books let's
say for example
we want to get the first non-fiction
book that we can
find here so as you already remember
essentially we can add here a filter so
we can add here the
filter type and say we're looking for a
non-fiction book
so we can change that here
and for sending this again we'll only
get non-fiction books
so let's try again to set this to
a variable and see what happens
the question is like how can we get this
information
previously we have manually set this
variable but
we still want to avoid getting this we
want to
set this variable automatically and this
is totally possible so let's go here to
the scripting part
where we have the tests and we also have
here the response
so let's imagine that we want to get to
this id here
id 2.
first of all we're going to define a new
variable
called response and we're going to do
the parsing
opm.response.json will parse the
response.json into a javascript object
open up again the console
send the request and we'll see here
the data that we have
this data format is different than what
we had before
because it is a list of books or
how is it called in javascript it's an
array now recontains
multiple objects so this book i
with id2 this is an object then there is
the next object with
the other book with id5
if we try inside the console log
to do something like response dot id
you'll see here that it says undefined
and the reason for that
is because we first have this array
so we need to get that data from the
array first
and then we have an object where we can
call the property id
[Music]
the array that we have has keys
essentially a way that allows us to
access that information
for example if i write here a square
bracket
and i say zero this will get us the
first
element from the array computer science
we always count from zero so this is why
the first element has the key zero let
me demonstrate this
you will see here we get this two
now the problem here is that this first
book
is not available so
what we have to do is to get the second
book on the second book
we'll have the key one
trying to get that and we'll get id
number five here
that's all good the problem is
if this data set changes or for example
the first one will become
available or the second one will become
unavailable
having this hard-coded data here will
kind of
like cause us some issues for example
even if something changes in the
parameters we're no longer setting this
non-fiction filter here
the id that we can get if we keep it
hard-coded like this
will be different all the time and we
don't want this this will be too risky
so we have to look into a different way
of handling this
because this is an array we can use
a specific function then this array has
so we can define here a new constant
let's call it for example none
non-fiction
books and we can
get a response i'm gonna use the method
filter
and inside here we can define a
condition
now the condition that we're going to
define here is
inside another function
where we will receive a parameter book
and then with this book we can define a
condition so for example book
dot available
and we can decide here
if available should be true
from the two books that we have here we
can notice that the first one is not
available
but the second one will be available and
let's just assume
all the time we'll know that we'll get
one of these books
so now what we can do is from this
non-fiction books
we can get the first element that we get
because we will know that this will be
available filter
will throw out any books
that are not available and will only
give us the books that are available
and then by specifying non-fiction books
0
we'll essentially get the first book
that is available and that is a
non-fiction book
and you will see it here being locked
in this way you have managed to get to
this property that is really hidden
inside the response
without actually having to write
something hard-coded with the only
assumption that all the time we should
find at least one non-fiction book that
is available for most apis this is a
assumption that's quite valid the
criteria that you use here
totally depends up to you you can search
for a specific name
or by any other characteristic if you
find yourself in a situation where you
need to filter
a list of different objects and extract
only one
now so far this hasn't helped us a lot
so what we want to do next is to also
actually set that variable
luckily postman has another code snippet
that we can use
and the code snippet is called set a
global variable
so i'm going to click on it it will be
generated here
and all we have to do here is to specify
the following
we'll specify here the book id
this is the name of the variable you can
call it as you wish
and then we also have to specify the
value and when you're specifying the
value
you want to make sure that you're not
putting anything between codes
because this will be a string but since
we have here a javascript
object we will be putting that
now of course we don't want to have the
object itself
we want to get only a property of that
object so i'm going to write here that
id so we're getting this object
and we know that the property id is 5.
after sending this you can click on this
i icon here
and you will see pretty similar to the
other variable that we have manually set
that now book id has value five
so it means that now we can get
an updated book id with our requests and
we don't have to do anything else
now just in case something does happen
and no book is being found
it kind of makes sense to test
so just in case we don't have any books
there is a postman test that will let us
know hey
we couldn't find any non-fiction books
and in this case we're not gonna be
directly asserting the response
but kind of like indirectly through this
filter that we have
so let me show you what i mean by that
let's go ahead and write a new test
pm.test
and let's say here book found
this is the name of the test this will
be the
callback function and
inside let's try to write an assertion
instead of logging this i'm going to
define a variable called book
and i'm going to write a few
expectations so i'm going to use
pm.expect
i'm going to expect book
to be an object
so first of all we expecting that book
is an object
and additionally we can write other
assertions for example
pm.expect book
that available
to be true
and this is absolutely the same as
writing
pm.expect book available to equal
true it's just a different way of
writing it
so again this just ensures that
everything is
as we expect it to be
what we're setting here instead of using
this we can use this
book.id
and we can also try to make this fail
now it may fail
in a different way we can write here for
example instead of
equals true we can set a filter that
will never exist
and we're gonna get here actually first
of all a type error because we're trying
to get
property id of something that's
undefined
essentially postman will anyway warn us
that
something didn't went well but
this additional test that we can write a
just good
place to ensure that we document how the
api should behave and we document what
we expect to get back
so i'm going to fix this and let
everything run properly
so for example just to ensure that
everything works properly
we can also surround this by something
like
let's say if
book
only then we're setting this global
variable
so let's make this fail again
and then we'll see here that we don't
get this error anymore from javascript
which says here book found has failed so
it hasn't found a book
and then we're making the expectation
undefined to be an
object so this is a way to get around
that javascript error that you have seen
previously
but apart from that this is how
we ensure that what we have written here
in terms of javascript
is being properly handled just in case
something
unexpected happens
and now it's time for another short
assignment for you
we have identified here a book and we
have seen that it is available
i wanted to give you the opportunity to
write an expectation on your own
and i want you to expect that this book
is from the type
non-fiction even if we have used this
parameter here
and we specified that is non-fiction
just wanted to test it again
and also try to make it fail i'll give
you a few seconds to pause the video
and to do the assignment on your own and
after that i will show you
how i would solve it
all right this is pretty easy i'm going
to simply duplicate the last expectation
that we have here because from the
structure
is already the way it should be and i'm
going to
change here property from available to
type
and the type that we're interested in is
non-fiction
so let's fix this error here from above
in true
and we have tests that are passing
let's disable the type
and maybe we can even change it to
fiction but essentially the first
available book that we found was a
fiction book
so for that reason the test is failing
so now we have ensured that whatever
we're getting back
is indeed a non-fiction book because
this was the original requirement
and after one assignment what is better
than doing another assignment
because practice really matters now
this assignment will have two points the
first of it
is i want you to use this variable book
id that we have
saved here and you've seen that it has
been properly saved as a global variable
i wanted to use it in a get single book
and also in order book this is in the
request body
and this is here as a parameter
since you're already looking at a get
single book request
how about checking again if inside here
so let's write for example five
i'd like to check that the current stock
is actually greater than zero
and i'm going to give you a small hint
on how to do this
so i'm going to go ahead here just
simply copy the structure
of the test here
let's say i'm going to write it is in
stock so this would be the name of the
test
and the expectation would be pm.expect
one two be above
two a very simple expectation here that
will
help you out when asserting that the
current stock
is greater than zero
and you will see here that one is not
above two so it's not
working i'll give you a few seconds to
pause this
and after that i will continue solving
the assignment
all right so the first part of the
assignment is super super easy
we only have to replace here any
hard-coded values
with what we have here book id as a
global variable
and you can see it's being rendered
and we also have this order book
and inside here is again super simple
you only have to get that right and we
can test if it's working properly
we're getting no errors so all good
there
going back to the test that we wanted to
check here
the property that we want to use is this
current stock
so as you recall first of all we have to
parse
the response so we define a variable
called response and we're using
pm.response
dot json we're parsing that
and what we can do here is to expect
that response
that current stock to be above zero
super simple the problem that you're
getting here
is you're gonna get this weird error it
says
stock is not defined and you'll probably
not understand
what is this referring to the problem is
this dot syntax this dot notation
when getting properties from an object
works with this kind of like
simple properties that are one word when
you have this
dash here this hyphen here this would
kind of like break the syntax and you
have to fall back
to the other syntax with square brackets
so we
adding here this square bracket we are
putting it
the name of the property as a string
here can be single quotes or double
quotes
use as you wish and that will get us the
right property and we'll see here now
it is in stock we're trying to get
something that's not in stock
for example book id 2 i think it was not
in stock
we'll have here failing test expected 0
to be above 0 so that's not working
but with our book id here
it's working properly
all right so this was the assignment
now it seems that we have all elements
that
can help us do proper test automation
we have written api tests that ensure
the
api response as we expect the api to
respond and generally how
we expect the api to work and we also
have added all these variables
and essentially we don't have to copy
paste anything anymore from one request
to the next one
the next step is to move into the
direction of automation
we want to take this request and instead
of
going request by request from one
request to the other
and running this manually we will use a
built-in tool from postman
this is the collection runner and the
collection runner allows us to execute
the entire collection with just one
click
so let's see how this works
first of all i have too many requests
here open again
so i'm gonna simply go ahead and close
all of them i don't need them everything
is saved
and here in the lower part of the screen
it's a bit hidden
you'll find this button a runner so i'm
gonna
click on it in earlier postman versions
you could start to run it directly from
the context menu
of the collection itself not sure if
this will be
added back but just in case if you're
watching this a bit later on maybe this
has come back here in the collection
just saying
all right so this is essentially the
runner and in order to run this
collection we're gonna essentially drag
and drop it here
and here is the run order the run order
is in which order will this request be
executed now for example here
the way we have organized the requests
here in the collection this is how they
will be
executed for example here
the way we did it is before actually
ordering a book we first registered our
api client so it may
make sense to do this somewhere before
that of course this is not impacted
so if we don't want this anymore we can
simply close this all together
open the collection runner again drag it
here
you will see the new order you also have
the possibility of reordering requests
or disabling some requests that you
don't need
okay so this is in terms of in which
order will this request be executed
there are some other things that we want
to do
one very important one is to save the
responses
and just in case something goes wrong by
saving the responses we'll be able to
take a look at what has happened
okay so let's click on this button and
let
the runner do his job
now as you can notice some of the
requests have been successful in terms
of testing
and some of them have failed
for example here register api client
this has failed
and we already knew that sending the
same data will
cause this to fail so no big surprise
there
there are also some other ones who have
failed here
for example get an order has failed
now if you want to better understand
what has happened we can
take a look here
and we're looking here at the request
we'll see that we have this order
and let's try to understand like what
has happened here
you'll notice here that we have this
order id but this is the
order id that we have manually hard
coded here
we are not updating this with every
execution
and yeah this is your next assignment
do you have any idea how we can fix this
i will give you a few seconds to pause
this video
and to try to do this assignment on your
own
all right obviously manually hard coding
this
it's not the best approach and as you
can see we totally forgot that
this thing was manually added so what we
have to do here
is to fix this order so where is this
coming from it's coming from
this post request order book
and we have added a test but we're not
doing anything else
so let's submit it again this is the
property that we're interested in
if we want to be very sure that this is
working properly
we can use again console.log but just
gonna
speed it up a bit so again we're parsing
the response
i have to do this all the time and it's
not
pm.request.json it's pm.rt
i have to be careful what i'm writing
and
we're going to set the global variable
and we're going to be careful to name it
order id
so this is the key this is how the name
of the variable will be
and we're going to get it from response
dot order id
you see i'm always copy pasting this
because i don't want to make any
mistakes
in terms of how i name this
let's run it again we inspect it
and what do we see here it is absolutely
the same
order id as we have in the response so
it means this has been updated
and let's go back to our execution and
see if this
helps us get rid of the error i'm gonna
click here on run again
and now you can see that apart from the
register api client which has failed
the rest of them are working properly
and we have at least a status code test
that is ensuring that everything is
working properly
so good job
there is still something very annoying
about this register api client request
on one hand we don't want to get rid of
it
because we may need it later on but the
same time when we're automating now the
execution it's kind of annoying to have
it in there
and luckily there is a way how we can
influence the
order in which the requests are executed
and let me give you
an example i'm gonna go here to this api
status
request i'm gonna go to the tests and
what postman allows us to do is to
specify here in the code
where postman should go with the next
request
and currently this is done by writing
postman
this is instead of pm which is let's say
the newer way how we're interacting with
postman
this postman entirely is a bit older and
may get
replaced later on maybe at the time we
are watching this
currently in the version that i'm using
is still working
just saying but it allows us to specify
where the next request should go
and this goes by saying set next request
you'll see here the autocomplete
and here we will not specify an url
but it will specify the name of the
request
so for example here how about skipping
this
so the normal execution goes from here
to here to here to here
how about if we tell postman hey after
you've checked the api status
go to the list of books so we have to
get here the name of this
request exactly as it is i'm going to
simply
copy the name
and put it here as a string
so going back to the collection runner
i'm going to hit here this one
and if you look here you will see we had
api status
we have you know registered
the api client no it's no longer there
we have jumped directly to the list
of books and you know the flow continued
we
didn't want to skip any other requests
and you can see here that the register
api client is not present
an alternative to doing this is to move
this
right here at the end
and for example you can go to this
delete order request
and specify postman
set next request and this time
we don't want to go anywhere else we
just want to say
stop so in order to say stop we simply
say
specify null null means don't go
anywhere else
don't go here for example
gonna write again
this one with the api status has
absolutely no effect
it will go to the list of books just as
instructor
but this is also the normal behavior
what has changed here is that the delete
order request
will be essentially the last request
because it will instruct postman hey
stop the loop
now the thing with this loops is well
it can get crazy so you have to be very
careful when you're using these
conditions
and especially when you want to stop
something if you just want to skip
something that's totally fine but
just going to demonstrate what's
happening if i'm going to set it to
list of books
so it's running and running
and running so it will essentially run
forever
because we don't have any condition
that's telling it
to stop it will continue running
endlessly so i'm going to manually stop
it here
but especially if you want to do
automation it's probably not a good idea
to have a job
running all the time so just be very
careful
the conditions that you're writing and
use the collection runner to test it out
before you do anything else
so we have managed to automate this with
a collection runner we still need to
do this manual click there and
how about a way to run this collection
all the time
but not to worry about doing that click
and there is a functionality that is
built in imposement
and that is the monitors you can notice
here from collections a bit
further down you have monitors but also
from the context menu of the collection
you can select here monitor collection
so monitor collection
or clicking here on monitors and
clicking on create a monitor will
take you to this page so let's see here
the monitor name will be
check books api say for example we want
to
make sure that this books api is working
all the time without us having postman
open or without
starting the collection runner and we
can
define a frequency so for example we can
decide to run it every day run it every
weekday
and so on so there are a lot of
configurations that we can select here
and i will not get into all of them of
course what's important
here if you go this way you have also to
select the collection
kind of important so we're using the
simple book api the only collection
available in this workspace
i'm going to go ahead here click on
create
and once this monitor has been created
you don't need to do anything else
it will start on its own and you will
get a notification by email
something went bad of course just for
testing purposes
i will run it manually once but if you
don't write menu it will start on its
own according to the schedule
this execution will happen on the
postman infrastructure
and is totally decoupled from your
browser your computer or anything else
it is a relatively easy way to check if
something is working
in this case you will see here that it
says unhealthy
something went bad so we can scroll a
bit down here
and we'll see this report and it will
show us what has happened
and you will see here that the test that
we had here
the first request that we have they are
working but as soon as we do something
with orders
it will not work anymore the test will
fail
and would say here 401 unauthorized
so what's going on
there are not so many information in
regards to this
and you'll kind of have to guess like
what has happened
as you remember at one point we
have created inside our collection this
token which we have manually generated
and we haven't specified it in the
initial value
now when we have created this monitor
essentially we have shared this
collection with postman
and because we haven't provided the
access token they don't know
what they should do so this is why this
will fail
so if we go ahead and add the current
value
to the initial value save it
go back to the monitor
and run it again you will see now that
it has worked perfectly unfortunately
when something doesn't work well
here it's a bit harder to debug because
you don't have access to all the
information that you would normally have
inside postman
but especially when everything works
properly still a pretty powerful tool
now typically when anything fails around
automation or
with a collection runner or here with a
postman monitor it is typically
regarding missing postman variables
or something that hasn't been properly
set so
it's always a good idea to check that
first
the most important tool when trying to
automate a collection
run is newman a newman
is a cli tool that can take a postman
collection
run all the tests and at the end also
generate a report
if you know how to use newman you can
run a postman collection with api tests
on any professional server that deals
with
building and testing software like for
example jenkins
gitlab ci teamcity or anything else
that you use we're not going to look
into specific integrations
but i wanted to show you how we can
properly use newman
in order to use newman locally on your
computer you need to have node.js
installed
and i've added some details on how to do
that
inside the course nodes
i've opened here terminal and i already
have new one installed so i'm going to
write here newman
version and this will indicate that
newman has been properly installed on my
computer
now you're probably wondering how can we
get
access to the postman collection that we
have
and run it with newman and that is
definitely a very good question
first of all you can go to your
collection click on this
three dots and export this collection
as a json file i've created a new folder
to
hold this collection and i'm going to
simplify a bit the name
so it's going to be postman underscore
collection.json let me go ahead and save
it
an alternative way to doing this is
simply clicking here
on the context menu of the collection
clicking on share collection
getting a public link
and this public link will be generated
you need to pay attention that this link
does not automatically
get updated when you update something
inside your collection
and every time you make a change and use
this public link you have to come back
here
and click on update link to make those
changes visible
there's also a third way which i'm not
gonna show by
using a postman api postman also has an
api that allows you to get to these
collections by using an api key
that will add in the course notes some
details about it so there are three ways
on how we can do it
and i'll be demonstrating two of those
so from the terminal window that i have
i'm gonna go inside the folder where i
have saved this collection
this is a simple book api
and you will see that the postman
collection is here so i can simply use
newman
run and then i'm going to specify the
path to the collection
now you can notice that the entire
execution has been successful
all the tests have been generated
properly and everything seems to be
working fine
the alternative to using it as a file is
something like
newman run specifying here the link
where the collection is this can be
essentially anywhere
where it's reachable over http i'm going
to simply
copy the link that we have here as a
public link
and absolutely the same thing will
happen the reason why this may fail
is again due to variables or missing
tokens that you may have in your
collection
which either are not set as the initial
value
or are only available as a global
variable or something that hasn't been
exported
if you're using for example environment
you need to export those environments as
well and also specify them here
probably one of the most important
things when working with newman
is the possibility of generating reports
and one of the reports everyone in the
postman community
absolutely loves is the html extra
report
which will generate an html report now
it is not only nice to have a good
looking report
but it's also super helpful when you're
trying to debug something that went
wrong
this report will contain anything that
you log it will contain the full request
and the full response
to really really a lot of data i'm going
to link you in the course notes
also this reporter and how you can
install it
and i'll also go through the
installation steps and how to configure
it
in a bit so this is the command that you
need to run in order to
install this reporter i already have it
here
and in terms of the usage you can notice
here that
we have here newman run and it's the
collection
and all we have to do is specify the
reporter
we can use reporters which is my
preferred way of
specifying any flags or any additional
information to a command because
it's just much easier to read
so this is the newman run command
i'm gonna write here reporters
we're gonna still keep the cli reporter
this is the cd reporter what you're
seeing here
and without any spaces comma i'm going
to write
html reporter
and you're writing these commands it has
to be
exactly as it is so it's not html
report it's html extra sorry
but you have to write reporters space
and then specify the reporters it's not
reporters
equals or anything like this so be very
careful what you're writing
and also as you've seen i've written the
wrong reporter name
so this has been executed and i will
look inside the folder to see how this
report looks like
so inside a folder you'll notice that an
additional folder has been created
it's called newman and it contains here
an html report that you can open by
double clicking on it
what you'll see here is absolutely like
an overview of what has happened
in terms of requests and responses you
see how many requests have been sent
you can go to the requests you can
investigate
what happened with each request for
example order book you can open it up
you can see that has been a post request
you can see the address
you can see which request headers have
been sent so for example if you're
having like
any problems with authorization you'll
see here if the
proper token was sent if you see here
for example a postman variable that
hasn't been resolved
it's probably one reason why something
failed
so it really gives you a lot of
information in a very
nice and easy to read format both for
newman
and for the html reporter there are tons
of configurations that
you should know or especially if you
want to get started with this
you really have to get very familiar
with the documentation
try to understand which flags are
available what you can configure
you can specify the names of the reports
and many other things
we are coming towards the end of the
course and i wanted to give you the big
picture
in terms of automation and why newman is
so important and
where does everything that you have
learned fit
here's a pretty realistic project that i
have is an
api and essentially this api
has a built pipeline this is a piece of
software that
goes through a build process so this is
where the code is being compiled
it has some internal tests that are
being executed unit tests and also some
code quality
then this api is being deployed to a
server
and then i have here a stage of doing
api testing so once i have deployed this
api
somewhere i'm using a postman collection
in human to run some tests and to ensure
that the api is working properly
and just in case something is not
working properly
i rely on the postman test and on human
to notify me
and tell me inside this pipeline hey the
last change that you have done
caused some issues there were some tests
that failed
and this is where everything fits in
together so for example if i go to this
api testing stage here
and i'm looking inside the job well what
i will see here is the newman execution
i have here newman
run i'm running a collection i'm also
specifying some
environments so one environment here
that i'm using
i'm also specifying reporters like cli
reporter html extraj
unit and specifying where i should save
a specific reporter and so on
in addition to this in addition to
getting all this information here you
can go here to browse
and i will see here inside the newman
folder i'll have the html reporter
and here i'll be able to debug if
something went wrong
way to understand what has happened and
so on
so this is essentially how everything
comes in place
we have an api that we want to use and
test and ensure that it's working
properly
we have gone through the manual process
of testing it but once we are happy that
the api works and we have understood how
it works
we have documented that functionality by
writing
api tests and we have taken this
execution of the test
through different stages first of all
within postman
just to make sure that everything worked
properly but then we have used that
collection
and using newman we could essentially
automate this execution run and
integrate these postman
collections with many other tools we're
showing here the example we get live ci
you can do the same with jenkins with
teamcity
circleci or any other continuous
integration continuous deployment server
that you may be using
we have accomplished so many things in a
very short amount of time
i know this was a lot to take in but i
hope it was useful
and that this has opened your appetite
for learning more
if the scripting part was difficult and
you are still confused about javascript
variables objects arrays you can benefit
from taking
a basic javascript programming course
suppose you want to learn more about api
testing and postman
in that case you can explore topics
around data-driven tests
where you use an external csv or json
file
to fit different data sets in your
request
or schema validation where you
essentially test the structure of the
response in one go
instead of going property by property or
you can go deeper into authentication
and learn about
oauth2 you will find links to more
advanced tutorials
that show different things you can do
with postman in the course notes
hope you have enjoyed this course and i
would be very happy to see you again
bye now